Beware of Blade.
From the minute Marvel Studios made their
San Diego Comic-Con announcement that Moonlight
and True Detective star Mahershala Ali would
be leading a reboot of the groundbreaking
comic book movie Blade, fans have wondered
what Ali might look like all done up as the
legendary vampire-killer.
Well, they're in luck photoshop wizard and
well-known Marvel fan BossLogic recently tried
his hand at creating an edit of Ali's Blade
that would further boost hype for the film
and the end product has done that and more.
Shared on his Instagram page, BossLogic's
vision of Ali as Blade sees the actor wielding
a shotgun in one hand and Blade's signature
acid-etched sword in the other and features
a red-tinted version of his iconic sunglasses.
Fans on social media are going mad for this
intense red-and-black version of Blade, with
countless users praising BossLogic's work
on Instagram.
BossLogic may have had some help in creating
this edit, though, as it looks like he used
a promotional photo of original Blade actor
Wesley Snipes as the basis for the image,
then superimposed Ali's head over Snipes and
made some clever tweaks.
Still, BossLogic's edits are on-point and
his considerable Photoshop skills have gifted
fans a pic that's all kinds of sleek and spooky,
just as Blade should be.
"There are worse things out there than vampires."
"Like what?"
"Like me."
But BossLogic is far from the first person
to create a work of fan art that imagines
what Blade could look like when he makes his
Marvel Cinematic Universe debut.
One artist, Instagram's Goldie Arver, has
created a series of gorgeous concept illustrations
of Ali's Blade with fangs, a killer costume,
and round-framed glasses, while another Photoshop
expert, Apex Form, imagines Ali's Blade as
having glowing red eyes, heavy bullet-proof
armor, and two swords tucked in a pack on
his back.
Heck, this particular piece of Blade art isn't
even the first BossLogic has made.
Five months before Marvel announced the Blade
reboot and confirmed that Ali would be starring
in the lead role, BossLogic created an edit
that featured Ali as Blade with heavy tattoos,
fangs, reflective sunglasses, and his sword
sheathed in between his shoulders.
Clearly, almost everyone is stoked out of
their minds that Ali is playing Blade in the
upcoming Marvel reboot.
For a short while, however, there was actually
some controversy surrounding Ali's casting
but only because fans of 1998's Blade were
hoping that OG actor Snipes would have some
sort of involvement in the new film.
Luckily, this wave of criticism died down
when Snipes himself came forward to comment
on the project and Ali's casting.
Snipes shared in a statement obtained by ComicBook.com
that he understands why Marvel cast Ali as
Blade and not him: it's just the nature of
show business.
He also heaped praise on Ali, suggesting that
if anyone was going to follow in his footsteps
and take over the Blade mantle, Snipes would
want it to be him.
Snipes said:
"Although the news comes as a surprise, it's
ALL GOOD.
Such is the 'business' of 'entertainment!'
Much peace to the MCU crew always a fan.
Congratulations and Salaam to Mahershala Ali,
a beautiful and talented artist whose expressions
I look forward to experiencing for many years
to come.
Inshallah, we will someday work together […] Welcome
to the Daywalker Klique."
Fans are practically chomping at the bit to
see Ali's iteration of Blade up on the big
screen, and while this edit by BossLogic might
help satisfy that craving, nothing will compare
to the real thing.
Since Marvel hasn't yet offered up a release
date for their Blade reboot, however, BossLogic's
fan art will have to tide everyone over for
now.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.